[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in that was bad what
would I do without you you'll always
have me Elsa seemed weird to you she
seems like Elsa there's this voice voice
what does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming that's normal
where are we how did you get in the
force the mist parted for has impossible
where did you learn magic
[Music]
you can't follow me into fire then don't
run into fire
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all costs
I believe in you Elsa more than anyone
or anything
quick question is the hole putting up
some mortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]